I'm backstage here real-time we're here
with the new Late Late Show host James
Corden and Aloe Blacc of course was
fantastic on real time the great now
let's like put it in come on now and
we're talking about this Time magazine
article about the forever pill as
Bloomberg called it but it's it's a new
drug made out of like dirt that they
gave to mice and these mice are living
way longer than expected
yeah like some special dirt it's fancy
dirt but I want to know if I had that
drug would you guys twelve my question
is what is the quality of life for that
part last 50 years
it slows aging and it's right not to
share okay I'm gonna wait I'd love to
see cuz I'm up for living a hundred and
forty two years yeah if it's like ah
when I'm 60 70 I'm not only interested
in living another 50 years past what my
granddad was like where he just couldn't
even remember who he was like another 50
years of that is painful what do you
think yeah no I think we give this drug
to people like Stephen Hawking who can
figure out how to save the world rather
than hey Stephen Hawking really it's not
what he says it's the way says it okay
I'm happy to challenge myself to live to
142 without the pills 142 I don't know
what kind of experience I'm the grand
I'm the brand I'm the great you have so
many generations underneath you'd be
ridiculous like I do this approval
process though some people should get
the pill maybe others not so much
yeah yeah let's not give it to let's not
give it to you I'm pretty sure Kim
jong-un shouldn't have it it's fair all
homophobes and racists are out they
can't they go and get the pill yeah
that's it you're done yeah that's like
three people that can get the pillow it
should be a prize it should be a prize
if you do well in your life to that
point you get the pill and we're all we
all decide it would make people better
your life
we've noted nice yeah [ __ ] we've just
known it yeah so that's the criteria now
you can't get
he'll unless you've done well in life
and have you proven today that you're a
racist don't move your brothers and you
don't get the pill and you got our sorry
you're gonna die yeah if you're good and
normally if you're good and nice and
kind you live longer that's fair guys
we've absolutely got the cameras here
watch The Late Late shows many fantastic
gonna be [ __ ] but it would be fun either
way
nice to see you later black thank you so
much